my dad used to tell me all the time I
gotta be serious about something I
always want to constantly grow I never
want to get to a point where I feel like
I got to figure it out if you do the
hard work you put the time and that's
gonna separate you from everybody else
is moving to LA to do the exact same
thing that you're trying to do need
motivation watch a top tenant believe
nation what's up at 7:00 my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and chew on today's lessons from a man
who went from being the bad kid in his
neighborhood and taking his parents car
out to race it around the city with
never having any ambitions to become a
serious actor to enjoy massive success
as an actor in the black panther hit
movie he's Michael B Jordan and here's
my take on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one
go hard of course don't want like you
know success and nice things not that
good stuff of course you know but at the
same time you know that's not the
motivation my dad used to tell me all
the time I gotta be serious about
something I reflect and think about how
far I've come
yep I told myself at a young age that
was gonna like sacrifice I used to run
myself into the ground so like pure
exhaustion just because then I don't
feel like I deserve a fight why go so
hard in the gym go so hard in life I
want to feel the hardships of it how do
you push past the not wanting to do
something
do you remember why you're doing it
while you're working hard what's at
stake for me it's you know my family
all the dreams
you know see manifest I want to leave a
mark on this world I want to do things
that that's gonna last longer than my
physical body will rule number two do
great things I think I always want to
constantly evolve you know I always want
to constantly grow I never one that get
to a point where I feel like I gotta
figure it out you know I always want to
like kind of like push myself to be
better you know and do can do greater
things no matter what it is I mean I
want to be the best I'm a competitor you
know I like to compete you know like
growing out with you know with the name
Michael Jordan you know I've always had
a certain pressure pressure on on myself
and always having to kind of like you
know prove people wrong and and and
then I just kind of kind of kind of like
put an instant chip on my shoulder I
want it just to be great you know and do
great things and um and then and it also
helped people man I'm really big in the
next generation I feel like that's all I
saw that's the only way it's gonna get
better moving forward as if you know you
got to leave this world in a better
place than it was when you came in you
know I'm born in 87 - question mark I
don't know when I'm gone you know I'm
saying but I want to work on my - and
I'm saying I want we're going at that
time that I'm here and it is some and I
[ __ ] I could make it easier for the next
round of filmmakers and the next round
of actors coming up you know that's it
and I mean then I didn't and I'll be I'm
continually going out on that rule
number three my personal favorite
believe doing what I do you know
actually it's not just acting you know
what goes into becoming an actor people
see the end result I see the lights to
see that premieres I see the movies they
don't see the time that you put in by
yourself they don't see the the lonely
journey they don't see the moments where
you're sleeping in your car as long as
you stay up all night and you're
studying these lines rehearsing you know
and then you go in to audition you don't
get it but somehow you still have faith
and believe that you're doing you're
supposed to be doing rule number four
find mentors as an act there is such a
solo mission
you know you doesn't really happen that
often you know somebody that's kind of
been through it before I reach back and
you know give you some sound advice and
um I've been pretty lucky to have some
some good people you know you know Oprah
Winfrey you know just like you know
Oprah okay yeah I know right
oh just crazy you know able to you know
see her out and have and have a cool
conversation and it's not you know she's
always you know don't change just don't
change the way you are you know and it's
just it's kind of encouraging rule
number five learn to handle rejection
I'm interested in
the audition process is so tricky and
it's you know rejection it's hard at any
age but as a kid how did you you know
tolerate it I think it was a few times
that I thought I I booked it like for
sure and you didn't and then like just
being a heartbroken and um you know
having my mom and my dad kind of pick up
the pieces and I think that that was the
you know the few times that they
actually you know started to question
themselves are we doing the right thing
by letting them do it and do this um and
try to act and take on this this
profession that you know such a gamble
as a lottery you know such a lottery and
you just train yourself to like manage
your expectations for the most part when
it comes to auditions I used I know a
system that I started doing was like
after the audition after I left out I
would just throw my sides away you know
they really want me I'll just print them
out again you know I'll go out and I'll
go through the hassle go to Kinko's and
gotta have a print at the timing and
print them out again and that was just
my way of training myself to just forget
about it when you leave you know it's
not that out of your hands you DUP
you've done all you can do worrying
about it it's not gonna excuse me help
you get the job so um I mean it's tough
you know when it has nothing to do with
you you know you're something you have
the most talent in the world
I feel as though you're perfect for it
and still not get it because you know
maybe the other lead is a little too
tall and you you know and you guys don't
complement each other well on screen
that's nothing to do with you whatsoever
and I'm just kind of wrapping your head
around the process and knowing that it's
completely out of your hands it's just
easier for you to kind of let go and
move on to the next thing
rule number six do something different
relatively soon after the Fantastic Four
experience obviously apples and orange
is a much different experience and
assume again wine coolers the reason to
do it but is that was their significant
kind of trepidation given that you'd
been in this kind of universe so
recently zero hesitation it wasn't even
I didn't even really think about it as
soon as he gave me the call I was like
alright cool let's go let's just get
into it one because I love the space I
love Marvel you know I love the
characters and kind of like that world
so to give ya another chance at it for
sure because I had big hopes and dreams
and I had aspirations the first time
around so especially with this one to be
a part of this project to work with J
and I've always wanted to do you know
the act there's a lot of times like yeah
we're working together one day yeah
let's do it one day and it never happens
so to get a chance to do it on this
scale you know I'm saying you get to I'm
saying black strong male leads you know
I'm saying going back you know back and
forth toe-to-toe that was really
appealing and then you know to play a
you know an antagonist you know a
character that I've never I never played
before it was it was something different
and then of course we're going Ryan so
rule number seven do the work it's a
fearful business you know it's a lot of
uncertainty you never know what's gonna
happen
what's happening I what's gonna happen
next and you know what the future holds
for you but you got to kind of you know
be ambitious and you know have faith in
yourself and you know if you do the hard
work that's the thing you know I really
get in through these guys that you know
if you do the hard work you put the time
and that's gonna separate you from
everybody else is moving to LA to do the
exact same thing that you're trying to
do you know that's what separates the
boys from boys from men rule number
eight hunt for your food although you
probably don't have to an addition
auditions watch anymore this is a little
less but I don't mind going to like home
from our food I think it's yeah it's fun
that competition you know it's always
the usual suspects you see the same
people all the time right all the same
auditions and it's like it's it's a
process man auditioning is a it's it's
some actors hate it and I know as well
as one point of time where I really
hated it and then I started to become
more confident and I guess small
successes built up your confidence and
now then you don't really mind going on
auditions anymore it's just like I'll
going to read now they're approaching
auditions are kind of like this is my
tape instead of let me go try to give
them what they want now at now your mind
stare your mind state changes to this is
my tape you know i before you know you
give me any notes or anything like that
let me just give you my version cuz this
is my taking now it's a conversation
then you realize the power you have is
actors like once you're in that room
that's your time I audition could be so
fast when you go in there you know no
kit you know take your time like you
know this is this is my moment right now
so let's hash this out so what do you
feel what do you feel about the carrier
because I was thinking you know right
here on this line you know
you know he's he's not really talking
about you know the girl he wants he's
talking about that last drag the
cigarette he just had at the bar like
that's what I thought that meant and
then it's open dialogue that now the the
director you know whoever you're reading
for is oh it was a so open conference
it's a collaborative experience now
you're making something together rule
number nine
be prepared I'm working with Estes alone
taking on this franchise you know the to
have the legacy of rocky kind of like
just know all my shoulder a little bit
yeah and in the essence of time you know
I knew about this project about two and
a half three years ago so I started
training about a year and a half out
from we actually from actually like
filming huh secretly start so I started
training I was already halfway there so
about a year and a half of like like
literally you know brown rice grilled
chicken broccoli a gallon and a half of
water a day and working out two or three
times a day six days a week for about a
year and a half your body will change
Wow it will definitely change that's all
it takes guys that's it yeah now you
have water eat every two and a half
hours and keeping the tablets and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips have a secret Talent
my name is Michael B Jordan and my
secret Talent which is not about to be a
secret anymore
is irony it's a pretty wrinkled shirt as
you can see
lay it down like that on the back take
iron smooth deliberate strokes I don't
like it too crispy I don't like too many
creases but just enough to get rid of
the rabies it's kind of therapeutic you
know it's uh Sue's you comes you know
see how quiet and Zenoss like you know I
mean we have some candles lit some
incense or something and then I attacked
the sleeves and everybody has their own
technique they started different places
but end of the day it's about getting
the job done right
I've got two very special Michael B
Jordan bonus clips around finding your
inspiration and enduring hardships but
before that I want to get to the
commitment of the day you just watch
this great video don't just watch
another video without taking action what
did you learn from this video that
you're going to apply somehow to your
life to your business make the
commitment leave it publicly down below
so we can hold you accountable thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon and
enjoy the bonus clips
Ryne Cougars brain at all or what do you
think he'll bring you'll take from your
experiences with him till your first
directing effort yeah I mean honestly
he's the reason why you know I have the
self-confidence to go out there and do
it to be perfectly honest I'm just like
representation is so important and you
know on screen I think behind the camera
also see somebody my age that's you know
taking the responsibility of you know
however hundreds of millions of dollars
this project is you know it's it's
inspiring just let me know that I can do
that as well and then he also we don't
push me and told me there's never a
perfect time so just like suck it up and
just go ahead and do it yes you know
what you're doing so just to hear that
hearing that from him definitely pushed
me to want to want to get get behind a
camera a lot quicker it's hard for me to
encourage people to act because I know
the stress and the uncertainty and and
nothing's guaranteed and it's such a
such a dice roll you know it's such a
gamble
and but you can never touch somebody not
to follow their dreams and what they
want to do so it's always a constant
toss-up you know I was like I start off
with the negatives like okay I'm gonna
XYZ this is what it is McGraw you know
like you know you you might be on a
7-eleven diet for a while and it might
sleep out your car I mean I did it you
know I'm saying and and and you might go
on you know honey auditions and you
might get two callbacks you know and you
gotta have a thick skin you know it's a
very shallow very vain but industry you
know I said you could be a great actor
great actor have all the talent but you
might not be built for film you know I'm
Sally and that's a harsh way that people
don't that people can't take so if I lay
out everything like that and people
still want to do it then I might okay
cool let's go you know I
you know pass along that alone if it
means good I think that's my
responsibility to is to tell you you
know it's easy to see the good stuff
when it's successful when it happens the
right way you know and like the the
reward but very rarely people like
really understand like the lows you know
like how lonely this industry is to you
know how much you spent time you spend
by yourself you know I mean and and and
alone and and you know I hate when
things get bad it's it's you know it's
it's that could be a real lonely place
man the most important word ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]